So Twitter, for the first time has flagged
Trump tweets as possibly misleading.
Essentially a flag they've established to
signal fake news.
And Donald Trump has absolutely lost his mind
and is talking even about shutting down social
media platforms that do this.
Now, I told you yesterday that Twitter, they
kind of have special rules for politicians
and prominent figures where normally, for
example, you would not be allowed to accuse
random people of murder on Twitter and sic
your followers on them.
But Donald Trump did that to Joe Scarborough.
And Twitter allows it because they say when
Trump does it, it in and of itself is newsworthy
and thus it should be allowed to stay because
it is the catalyst for much reporting.
It's newsworthy in and of itself because of
the person who is doing it.
So yesterday, Donald Trump sent out two tweets
with absolute lies about vote by mail and
Twitter, flagged them both and provided fact
checking.
And Donald Trump lost his.
You know what?
And this is a technique that Twitter put in
place similar to one that Facebook has when
fake news articles are posted.
And this is infuriating to Trump.
Let's check out the claims and then the truth.
And this is so important, not just because
good for Twitter, for fact checking the president,
but it's important because vote by mail is
again becoming sort of like the new battle
line in the upcoming 2020 election.
Donald Trump said there is no way zero that
mail in ballots will be anything less than
substantially fraudulent.
Mailboxes will be robbed, ballots will be
forged and even illegally printed out and
fraudulently signed.
The government of California, the governor
of California, is sending ballots to millions
of people.
Anyone living in the state, no matter who
they are or how they got there, will get one
that will be followed up with professionals
telling all of these people, many of whom
have never even thought of voting before,
how and for whom to vote.
This will be a rigged election.
No way.
Now, as you can see, if you're looking at
this, there's a flag there with an exclamation
point that says get the facts about mail in
ballots, sort of an instant fact check, which
tells you, if you click it, that Donald Trump
is falsely claiming that mail in ballots would
lead to a rigged election.
That's not true.
There's no evidence that mail in ballots are
linked to voter fraud.
Trump falsely claims California is going to
send mail in ballots to anyone no matter how
they got there, implying undocumented immigrants
would get ballots, in fact.
Not only is that not true, only registered
voters would receive ballots.
If you live in California but are not registered
to vote.
You won't get a ballot at all.
Five states have already voted entirely by
mail.
All states offer some kind of absentee voting,
according to NBC News.
Also part of the fact check now, the right
wingers who love to cry about anti conservative
discrimination on Twitter and Facebook.
They are slamming Twitter for this.
But this is exactly what Twitter needs to
be doing.
CNN and MSNBC and FOX News should be doing
it during Trump and Kaley Maguindanao, his
press briefings.
I've talked about responsible platforming,
instant fact checking.
This is how Donald Trump's tweets should also
be handled.
Now, the amazing thing is when Twitter did
this, Trump tweeted an apology for spreading
fake news.
Trump deleted his tweets and he thanked Twitter
for correcting him.
Now, obviously, that's not true.
Trump absolutely lost it when Twitter did
this, attacking them.
And CNN and The Washington Post for some reason
tweeting, quote.
Twitter is now interfering in the 2020 presidential
election.
They're saying my statement on mail in ballots,
which will lead to massive corruption and
fraud, is incorrect based on fact checking
by fake news.
CNN and the Amazon Washington Post adding
that, quote, Twitter is completely stifling
free speech.
And I as president will not allow it to happen.
Then Trump actually tweeting about shutting
platforms down, tweeting, quote, Republicans
feel that social media platforms totally silenced
conservatives voices.
We will strongly regulate or close them down
before we can ever allow this to happen.
We saw what they attempted to do and failed
in 2016.
We can't let a more sophisticated version
of that happen again, just like we can't let
large scale mail in ballots take root in our
country.
It would be a free for all on cheating, forgery
and the theft of ballots.
Whoever cheated the most would win.
Likewise, social media clean up your act now.
Extremely dangerous dystopian totalitarian
language from the president.
We cannot relent on this.
I implore Twitter not to relent.
I implore other platforms and media outlets
on TV to.
Do the exact same thing.
Instant fact checking of Donald Trump.
What would be amazing would be if Twitter
fact checked Trump's attack on Twitter.
Right.
Like is interference in the elections.
Inclusive of just fact checking the president?
No, that's a lie.
Are Trump's claims about massive corruption
and fraud incorrect?
Yes, those are not true.
Is fact checking by CNN.
Incorrect?
No, Trump is wrong.
Now, it should be mentioned.
This is the president saying Twitter doing
fact checks has something to do with the Constitution's
First Amendment.
Trump is accusing Twitter of violating his
First Amendment rights.
Can you imagine?
Can you imagine a president this incompetent
when it comes to the basics of what the First
Amendment is?
Twitter has the same First Amendment right
to decide which falsehoods and lies they will
allow to spread on their private platform,
just like other private businesses have the
ability and right to do.
This was a big topic when I was on with Joe
Rogan on Friday.
What should the limits be here?
Whose rights extend how far when it comes
to what Twitter can be compelled to do versus
what Twitter is allowed to do as an organization
that has terms and conditions? Trump is going
to put huge pressure on Twitter and other
platforms.
It is very clear this is part of the culture
war.
This is part of the battle lines now.
I want this to escalate.
Twitter actually could get Trump to completely
lose his mind if they keep up the fact checking
with all of his tweets with accurate information.
Good for Twitter.
I'm not endorsing or criticizing anything
else about Twitter other than this is the
right thing to do.
They should keep doing it.
Look at how instantly triggered Donald Trump
was will follow what will certainly be a wild
next 24 to 48 hours as the fallout from this
continues.
Keep an eye out.
One other warning and then I want to move
on.
Keep an eye out for how people around Trump
are going to create specious special pleadings
to argue that Twitter should be banned from
doing this.
Essentially, we'll follow up on that when
it happens.
Well, let's give it time to develop.